we've seen Donald Trump seem confused or
lose his place or forget the words of
Psalms and prayers while in church but
that's sort of to be expected with Trump
Trump was never really religious his
entire the Bible is my favorite book
thing was obviously a farce
from the get-go to appeal to evangelical
voters which happened to work on them by
the way which is a whole other problem
but that that's all that that was but
the frequency with which Trump is
forgetting words or confused by words on
his own teleprompter two feet in front
of him is growing in regularity and it
happened again over the weekend so for a
second time Donald Trump is on video
appearing confused and disoriented
during the national anthem our national
anthem by the way not the Russian
national anthem it might make more sense
if he was confused during that but or
any other of course why would I mention
that one but during our national anthem
this time it's at a football game in
Alabama Trump of course trying for the
third time in three weeks to go to a
sporting event where something other
than booze and chance of lock him up are
hurled at him so take a look at the
video you'll notice Trump stop singing
towards the end of the national anthem
sort of seems confused and kind of
starts patting his chest almost like a
nervous anxiety motion everybody around
him keep singing
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this isn't the first time that this has
happened in public back in January of
2018 similar thing happened we covered
it at the time in the middle of the
national anthem during a football game
in Atlanta Georgia here's video of that
just to remind you
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so I think you get the idea so what
matters here I mean on the merits this
is not about patriotism this isn't some
stupid thing of unless you know the
lyrics by heart
you aren't a patriot or anything stupid
like that this is about Trump continuing
to display outwardly signs of either and
I don't know which it is or it could be
both cognitive decline and or drug
addiction and interestingly I've seen
more and more speculation lately that
these things are drug addiction not
cognitive decline you might remember
that a month ago we brought you the
story of Donald Trump's office being
photographed with boxes and boxes of
sudafed a particular type of sudafed
that is actually sold in the UK the
packaging from the UK stacked up in
Donald Trump's desk behind him over his
left shoulder and of course this is
something that it is a medication for
nose congestion but it can be crushed up
and snorted like a recreational upper
and I read a bunch of commentaries about
this national anthem video saying the
Trump swing and being unable to sit
still and unable to concentrate it seems
more like drug addiction than cognitive
decline but truly who knows all we know
is that it's bad Republicans should do
the patriotic thing call it what it is
it's just it's a person who's
compromised that's what we can say for
sure whether they're compromised by
drugs or a cognitive decline or a life
of narcissism it doesn't really matter
it doesn't really make a difference to
us at this point
just put party political party aside for
a second and say we can't have a
president who's so compromised now of
course the side story here is once again
Donald Trump at a sporting event after
being booed at the Major League Baseball
World Series game five a couple of weeks
ago at a UFC fight in New York City last
week desperate to find a sporting event
at which he is not overwhelmingly booed
and he found one in Alabama football
I guess now there were some reports
saying the reason he wasn't booed is the
school say it sent out a letter saying
you will be punished if you boo the
school denies it the the way this the
letter was worded was anybody who causes
a disruption during Donald Trump's visit
will be immediately removed from
their seats and what they're saying is
that that was more about being
disruptive to other students or whatever
but very clearly not any kind of
restriction on free speech you be the
judge
at least that's the position that the
school is taking on this one let me know
what you think let me know what you make
of the video we will be maybe doing a
poll question on our Instagram account
about this at david pakman show follow
david pakman show on instagram and while
you're there follow me on instagram at
david pakman we will take a quick break
I still want to talk about Rudy Giuliani
or Giuliani and his latest antics sean
hannity has exploded over being
implicated in impeachment we will also
talk about those who claim to be about
dialogue shutting down dialogue what a
big shocker and also I've got some book
recommendations for you today all of
that and more coming up on today's
program